hi I'm Ross amen we're the tough
brothers we created change things and
we're gonna be going through the show's
biggest moments
[Music]
well we always knew we wanted to show to
open with a bang and you know when this
when we came over this idea was always
about a supernatural kidnapping so we
knew that was gonna be our opening hook
we were really inspired by in close
encounters a third time in terms of the
kidnapping of Barry where it is really
terrifying minute end of the day you
don't fully see what happened which is
why we wanted to just go to that light
bulb at the end instead of actually
showing that dimmer Gordon taking will
we wanted to feel like he just vanished
into thin air and then our characters
have to sort of piece together what
happened and kidnappings are hard enough
to solve but how do you solve it if it's
supernatural
[Music]
[Music]
so for barb she gets taken at the end of
episode 2 season 1 and they ended by
Nancy banded by Nancy and then and then
she meets her end at the top of episode
3 Barbara actually made it further and
longer than she was supposed to make it
and the original pilot that sold to
Netflix barb met her end at the end of
the first episode we were of course
surprised but sort of not surprised by
Barb's explosion in popularity after the
show was released I still get questions
about barb it's never gonna end
she's gonna haunt me for the rest of my
life I think but Shannon purser it's
just she was incredible and that's not a
lot of episodes and not a lot of time to
make the kind of impact that she did
what does she think she had something
like 25 lines and now there are murals
or her fan dedications and it's still
unbelievable
Funko dolls
[Music]
we always knew we wanted to her to have
sort of a Ouija board type communication
with will I think very early on we had
the idea of communicating through lights
that we were going to use I mean even in
the first episode when will disappears
that the light bulb in the shed goes
bright to this day we don't really
remember who came up with the Christmas
lights idea but the minute you know we
had wood you know Wynonna cast in that
role we thought this is sort of her
Close Encounters Richard Dreyfuss moment
yeah yeah he becomes obsessed with this
with this image of this mountain and he
creates and the mountain out of mashed
potatoes and he's he's crazy but he's
not crazy he's actually right and so we
wanted to give Joyce character play by
Wynonna that kind of a moment that's her
moment I miss miss lights much and we
wanted to kind of destroy the house in
the same way that Dreyfuss destroys the
house in close encounters so we've done
that two seasons now but then we decided
that might be enough she's destroyed the
house two years in a row now so we take
a break on season three
okay okay text me where are you
she's communicating him and you know of
course it you know it starts with what
seems to be a sweet communication him
telling will telling Joyce that he's
he's okay and it quickly becomes
terrifying when he spells out are you
and and you realize the doom Oberon is
right behind and that's one of our sort
of our first clearest glimpses of this
horrific monster
you know season one we were we were
attempting to do everything practically
we tried to shoot the DeMorgan
coming through the wall but it looked
absolutely ridiculous so that was that
was the first shot that became full CG I
hope that footage never sees the light
of day yeah I mean because it's funny
it's certainly not scary it's early
enough
[Music]
yeah so if government officials make a
really good-looking fake body and we
knew we wanted to at the end of three we
wanted this discover this body and we
want it to to feel the impact of that on
our kids and really remind everyone else
how serious this is so even though the
show has fun there there are real stakes
and Will's in real danger
but of course it's it's a shock when you
realize that this that will it's not not
in fact that at all and really for
hopper it's this epiphany that oh my god
Joyce Byers has been right that in this
whole time there is something more going
on here and after that he really just
goes down goes into the deep end of sort
of investigating this conspiracy so
that's a huge turning point for his
character that was really fun and not
that that that was a real you know
prosthetic build of Noah's body that was
incredibly frightening ly realistic and
it's still it's still around and like
the in the warehouse so every once in a
while I run into it it looks like you
know a dead no nap it's very disturbing
freak does it there's a dead barb there
somewhere somewhere too but Noel gets a
kick out of it he loves it
you know he showed it to his mom he
likes to freak out his parents with it
yeah Drake this office opens in five
for great
[Music]
we really wanted the show when Mike goes
over the clip first of all I mean that's
obviously a crazy thing in there but
it's just how much he values his
friendship with Dustin so it's a it's a
it's a really brave thing as well and we
wanted the bully storyline to reach a
real climax which is sort of what that
whole core sequence does and obviously
he's saved at the last second by 11 I
just when I think about it was a very
difficult shoot on that quarry I just
think just to get down there with the
kids and I don't believe that Cory's
there anymore but it isn't a lot of
movies and you know we're happy how it
turned out
[Music]
[Applause]
you know we wanted to have our sort of
iconic ET bike chase sequence we knew we
knew we needed the government chasing
after our kids you know we were pretty
adamant at the time that we did not want
that to be a CG van and that we really
wanted to flip a van turns out it's very
difficult to flip a van of that size all
the way over you know the first time
they did it I think it didn't it didn't
work at all motion our camera image our
camera of course did kids were not fair
you shoot the van separately and then
the kids so nobody was actually ever in
danger I think God and then of course
there was pressure again to do the
sequence CG and we said let's just our
special-effects guru Pius was confident
that it would work the second time and
we took the chance roll the dice then
the van flipped and that's what's in the
show yeah yeah I was perfect no CG
involved except pacing in them kids
[Music]
you go to school dances with someone
that you know someone that you like a
friend my friend some of my good
[Music]
whoof Mike 11 in in season 1 we knew we
wanted their relation to build this
moment sort of they're waiting for
things to go down and they're at their
school in there alone and Mike is just
sort of fumbling with his feelings it's
this idea of like you know he's he's
still a kid in this idea of sort of your
first first crush and how can he sort of
that interaction between them we thought
Finn Finn and Milly just did such such
an incredible job and of course we plant
there
the snowball which you know doesn't pay
off until until the end of end of season
two but we were excited that was again
one of the first things we had for
season two is we've got to pay off that
discussion about the about the snowball
though they have in season one Mike has
to take a Lover's of the snow that's
right right
[Music]
come on you son of a [ __ ] see it
so the you know the end of season one it
was a kind of you know with the teens we
wanted a very nightmare sort of on Elm
Street climax they're always always
absent these movies we loved we loved
booby traps I mean so who doesn't love a
good booby trap so the idea was always
like you know we got to have the teens
try to take this guy out
you know we were filming with a minute
with a guy in a suit so we actually had
we had the monster there of course this
is where Steve kind of makes his first
turn into good guy territory because
prior to that he was you know a pretty
big douchebag if not a charming
douchebag it wasn't originally supposed
to be Steve who rescued them in this
moment I think it was um it was
originally going to be Jonathan's dad
Lonnie and so and but but over the
course of shooting like we all kind of
fell in love with this kid Joe Curie and
and and Steve started was originally
going to be kind of an unredeemable
character the charm was so undeniable
that we were like we got it you know I
think he's got to be the gun who comes
in and saves the day and he took his
jock athlete abilities and used them to
help defeat this monster
[Music]
when eleven sort of ends up you know
she's weakened but eventually she sort
of uses a lot less of her powers in
order to confront this demo Goran is
about to kill her new friends so she
sort of uses all the last of her
willpower to confront this thing she
slams it up against the classroom wall
and she ends up making it dissolve and I
think what we were really excited about
that scene was that we were going to
play it like an action movie were gonna
play it sadder and slower and more
tragic goodbye Mike
[Music]
in entreated us as it is saying goodbye
in the same way that et says goodbye to
Eliot and at the end of that film so we
saw more as that than more than a really
a fully triumphant crushing of this
creature that you might see in a typical
action or horror film I remember
shooting that scene too and that was one
of those scenes where Milly and you know
you have to keep in mind you know I mean
she was only 11 actually age 11 at the
time she was just it's so incredible it
was one of those things where everyone
on the crew just was blown away by her
performance and I think we all knew we
had you know gotten to something special
that day and that was when we even got
into the editing room I think we saw
that sequence cut together for the first
time it had that music from our
composers Carmichael already in there or
sound designer had already done pass on
it and we haven't touched it
we never touched it that was the scene
we said that was it that's incredibly
rare you know it just came together
[Music]
what you're late yeah I lost track of
time I'll signal next time all right and
it's it's 8:15 it's not obviously you
know even though 11 vanish we reveal at
the end of the first episode of season 2
that 11 is alive and we really wanted to
do it in a way that we did this sort of
slow panning shock around all of the
cabin until we finally landed on her we
just sort of wanted to tease her and
hear her voice and just you know you
wanted the audience to sort of sit up
and be like could it be isn't really her
and then finally land on her new this
big revealed and not only she alive but
that she's been living with with hopper
this whole time you know when we were
talking about early season 2 ideas I
think maybe that was you know idea
number 2 idea number one was that you
know we'll of course was going it you
know was gonna be possessed by this
thing dealing with the the after-effects
of having been in the upside out for
that long and idea number two was you
know we had to put off for an 11
together and a lot of that was in
response to shooting season 1 and us
being pretty consistently blown away by
both David Harbor and Millie's
performance and we thought what happens
if we put these two powerhouse actors
together we've got to do that
you know there's a sequence it's in
episode 3 when of season 2 when will its
pulled into the upside down when he's in
the school which is sort of a very
Nightmare on Elm Street II / The Shining
kind of vibe crew and and then he runs
out onto onto the field I mean I'm
thrilled with how that turned out and as
far as the show goes it really did a lot
what we wanted to do with season 2 which
was sort of up the scale and up the
scope there's something about the image
of that enormous monster towering over a
small little will on that field they got
that huge crane shot up may Noah feel
absolutely tiny and it's just I think a
pretty effective sequence we knew that
getting the shadow monster to work
wanted them made of all these little
tiny particles and we knew that was
going to be difficult and that was that
was the first sequence where the shadow
monster I think really really came
together and we were were confident that
this was going to work
dirt
[Music]
yeah dart uh you know the gremlins like
way you know Dustin this is the moment
where Dustin realizes that this cute
strangely cute creature that he found is
not exactly friendly even though he has
sort of formed a bond with it it is in
fact a baby Dimmick oregon so we decided
that you know he had to do something
terrible and in really upsetting to
really hit home this idea that this is
not a friendly creature so I like cats
but we're dog people so we decided to
not hurt a dog and okay you imagine if
it was a dog
I don't think so this show wouldn't have
come back from that but it survived this
case a private cat but then and it'd be
did to make things better at the end you
know I don't know if you noticed but the
end when we visit Dustin's house at the
end of season two you see that they they
have a new cat twos so all is fine all
as well they have an end we have we have
a little not for Mews in season three
fans are paying attention and I think
Mews Mews lives on
[Music]
so Jonathan and Nancy is sort of the
love story that 15 hours to resolve and
to finally get there and I think that's
a lot of that has to do with sort of
Jonathan's sort of shyness and and and
reluctance and lack of confidence and we
knew going into season two that we
actually had to finally finally bring
these two together and we decided pretty
early on we wanted them sort of bonding
on this journey and well as they as they
make headway towards redeeming or
getting some sort of redemption for
Nancy's friend barb we looked at Indiana
Jones and the Temple of Doom where
Indiana's in one room and willies and
the other and you know she wants him to
come over in this circle this is really
fun back and forth which we really
looked at and you're just too proud to
admit that you're crazy that mean dr.
Jones if you want me Willie or you can
find five minutes you'll be back over
here in five minutes when we did the
scene with Jonathan Nancy just to build
up that tension of just cutting back and
forth between them and then suddenly
someone's right at the door and it just
led to this kiss so that was a that was
a big inspiration for us we wanted a
little bit of that screwball comedy a
feel between them that then led to this
this moment that I know a lot of fans
had been waiting for for a long time
you know there's been a lot of movies
I'm sure there have been TV shows also
about kids who are possessed by some
sort of evil so it was trying to always
try to figure out how do we not do the
same thing that's been done over and
over again and basically what we decided
to do was have this possession this more
slow drawn-out and have him just very
slowly become possessed by this thing
you know he almost for the the first
half of the season will operates just
like a spy on behalf of the good guys I
mean he's able to give them insight into
what this monster is doing and thinking
if you know what he's seeing and feeling
maybe that's how we can stop him maybe
all this is happening for a reason so
you get to the point where you're kind
of reassured and you trust what will is
going to say how can you not look how
innocent and cute this child is and then
so we thought it was fun to finally you
know we finally got to the point where
we go okay this is the moment that that
that will is going to turn and we don't
do a lot of twists on this show and we
thought that that was a great way to do
it you know the results of the death of
a lot of soldiers and this sort of
aliens like sequence down in the tunnels
it does not turn out well Probab either
but it's not not poor Will's fault he's
he's possessed
[Music]
[Music]
sister
we were always excited by this idea that
of course I mean 11 is the number 11
meaning there were a lot of others out
there this season 2 is a lot about her
searching for her place in the world and
where does she fit this idea of like you
know her finding someone her own which
is you know what she what she calls her
sister was an exciting idea for her just
to be like oh maybe this is my place in
the world so and I think Millie did a
great job in Linnea too when they have
that that sort of first meeting in our
warriors esque warehouse where you see
this sort of hope for the first time of
oh maybe this is that maybe this is my
place in the world but of course
ultimately she realizes that you know
she has already found a place and it's
belongs in Hawkins with her friends
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bah when we initially conceived of the
character he was just supposed to be
this dorky clueless boyfriend of Joyce
who gives will some terrible advice that
results in him getting possessed but
then when we cast Sean asked and it was
sort of like a joke Yuri situation that
we fell in love with with Sean and what
he was doing with the character and bob
was supposed to meet his end around
maybe Episode three or four and we just
we couldn't kill Bob it just felt it was
too hard so we just kept putting it off
and off and off until eventually we got
to the penultimate episode which is
episode 8 and we said you know if we're
gonna do this thing we have to do it
someone hangout ago Sean didn't want to
go we didn't want Sean to go the crew
had a in the cast at all fell in love
with Sean Astin at this point you know
it was a really sad night filming his
filming his death scene but it was also
oddly comedic because and we didn't have
a real demo dog there and in fact one of
our writers Kate happened to be visiting
set she was about the right size to play
a demo Goregaon a demo dog so he said
Kate will you just go in and she did and
she got blood all over her hands and
just murder Jonah stand
[Music]
well loving closing the gate is
obviously the climactic sequence to
season 2 and you know she's drawing from
all that she's learned this season
particularly with her journey to her
sister and sort of taking all this
painting that she's having using it to
close the gate and we wanted to also
have this sort of an emotional heft Oh
to not just be about action or just
using her powers it's really about 11
using everything that she's learning all
this hardship in her life and using that
to her advantage I wanted to find
something from the past
so things that anger she don't channel
it well of course papa
hopper is at the same time warding off
demo dogs and David was very excited to
be firing that gun and I think it was
fun it was just both of them in this
little cage and we're all surrounded by
green screen which is really the first
time we've done it because we try to do
as much practically as we can't it was
sort of an oddly intimate sequence to
film and it was it was a lot of fun I
felt like you know we stepped on the set
I was like what is this you know a
Marvel movie that we're doing all it's
nothing like it felt unlike anything we
had ever done before that was terrifying
we didn't have that long to shoot it we
had maybe a day and a half to do the
sequence they were both phenomenal in
that sequence and we're really proud
with how it turned out and a lot of it
the credit also goes to the visual
effects team who really kind of pulled
off a miracle getting that done in time
[Music]
hi we're the duffer's and these are some
of your favorite moments from season 1
and season 2 and we can't wait to see
what you respond to in season 3